[Music]
hi I'm Evan Carmichael welcome to
another edition of ask Evan in today's
video I'm going to answer questions from
whatever readers Franklin who's asked
about how to get started in the
construction business
so you're on in thank you for your
amazing tips I'm a 23 year old student
just finished my degree thinking of
starting a construction company the
problem is they don't have enough
capital please advise Franklin so
Franklin a couple ideas here for you the
first if you're trying to get capital
the most logical ways to go find an
investor who has the money partner up
with your expertise and you start the
business the challenge is if you're only
23 and you just graduated and you don't
have a lot of experience in the
construction field it'll be hard to
convince an investor to want to put
money into you so my suggestion be start
by working for somebody else so look at
the construction business find somebody
who you respect you want a model you
want to learn from work for them you're
earning money coming in to you but you
also learned the business so you're
making mistakes and then the business
while still getting paid from somebody
else you start making some connections
in the beginning industry and you learn
about what it is and you really want to
do and what you're good at so it's best
to do that when you're learning on
somebody else's dollar than spending
your own dollars once you kind of have
the feel for things and that thing will
do is try to serve a service based
business so maybe you can consult to the
construction industry it was other
services you can provide that don't
require a lot of capital because it's
just your time so you're you're sweating
it out you're constantly hustling you're
making a lot of sales but you don't
listen need a lot of capital to start
this type of business once you've built
up some credibility to experience I
would start talking to the banks and as
soon as possible start building a good
relationship with them because they will
be a good friend
hopefully as you try to build this
construction business asset based
businesses often have to work with the
banks together financially and approve
so as soon as you can try to start
building a good relationship with the
banks so they know you they know you pay
on time they think you're a good
business person you don't want to wait
till you know you're about to launch and
you don't know anybody there who can
kind of help you out so I build up that
credibility recognition you started your
own kind of service based business
you've built up some contacts through
working at a job and you built up some
credibility with your banks then you'll
have all the resources you need to go
out and start that construction business
and I might take a little bit of time to
get there but the chances of you being
able to launch and be successful go up
dramatically so I hope that helps if you
guys liked the video please give it a
thumbs up I'd also love to hear what you
guys have to say if you want to leave a
comment below the video and stay tuned
for the next episode
[Music]
you
[Music]